so guys we have some really bad news
Star Wars films are in big trouble so
Rogue Squadron which was the upcoming
Star Wars film released in next year in
December has been taken off the release
schedule hasn't been too late it has
been taken off to release schedule now
this could mean one of two things it
could mean that the film is completely
scrapped and will never see it alive
today or it could mean they got no clue
when this film would be made to they've
just delayed it and they're not given it
a date yet so who knows when we could
see this film if that's the case that
means the next scheduled Star Wars film
should release is in 2025 which is three
years from now this is the film from
tiger with teeny but after love and
funder I know some people won't be
excited for this film anymore but taiku
retini did direct one of the best
episodes from Mandalorian season one so
I still do have hope that this will be a
good film just hopefully it's lights on
the comedy elements but what do you guys
think of all this news I think it is
quite some bad news because Star Wars
films has been cursed since the release
of Rise of sky Walker films just getting
announced and canceled or delayed and
now we've got no clue when Rogue
Squadron is going to come out if it is
going to even come out so we may not get
a Star Wars movie for a few years now so
Disney really needs to fix up their Star
Wars movies but that's about it for this
video guys so we did enjoy please
consider subscribing and liking the
video thanks for watching